look you stupid bastard you've got the
arms left yes I have in life when
somebody gets injured it's just a stroke
of bad luck but in movies it's never an
accident an injuries are calculated a
meaningful choice by a writer or
director to tell us more about a
character or reinforce certain thematic
ideas each injury whether it's blindness
or becoming handicapped represents a
symbolic handicap and who they are as a
character and many of the most memorable
characters and movie moments were
greatly enhanced by this literary
concept so let's give some characters a
diagnosis first I have to convince you
that injuries are much more than just
physical in the film so let's say we
have a character returning from combat
adjusting to civilian life how do we
show his inner conflict symbolically
give him a limp a limp literally hinders
his mobility reflecting his struggle to
adapt to this new lifestyle and I know
that your therapist thinks he limps
psychosomatic quite correctly I'm afraid
so when he gets the thrill of the chase
in the limp finally goes away we know
what that means he said you forgot this
the ability to stand and walk normally
is a symbol of strength and
self-confidence why do you think the
Secret Service didn't allow any pictures
taken of FDR in a wheelchair walking or
the lack of it makes for a powerful
image in Forrest Gump lieutenant Dan's
character ARCA gets represented through
his injuries he wants to die a hero on
the battlefield when he fails he loses
the ability to walk his injury directly
contrasts Forrest who went from handicap
to always running in later scenes
lieutenant Dan's frustration is always
shown through his reliance on others to
move because he can't move himself where
he wants to be when he finally gets as
close as he can to the heavens
challenging the Fate he was supposed to
have that's when he finally moves on his
own and eventually yeah I got new legs
custom-made titanium alloy the fixing of
an injury always reflects the way a
character's inner self is being fixed
too if you want a character to have a
crutch in their psyche give them a
literal one there will be blood starts
with fury scenes depicting the dangerous
world of drilling underground Daniel
Plainview breaks his life falling into a
well and has to crawl all the way from
the well in the middle of nowhere to the
nearest town through an injury and how
he beats it we learn about his
ruthlessness better than dialogue could
ever tell us and in a way it justifies
his actions in the movie as much of a
bastard as this man proves himself to be
that courage that it would have taken to
do that actually gives him the heroic
right for almost everything that he does
throughout the rest of the movie but it
doesn't always have to be grandiose you
can even give a character a fake injury
to play with our expectations in Bonnie
and Clyde Clyde cut off his toe to get
out of doing work in prisons and this
impairment relates directly to his
sexual impotence with Bonnie in
literature and film a physical ailment
can often indicate a sexual ailment for
a man please limp in more ways than one
I ain't much of a lover boy in
rear-window Jeff is physically bound to
a wheelchair he doesn't want to marry
Lisa and his physical restrictions from
his injury compliment his view that he's
perhaps being sexually restricted as
well
and you love life not to ACTA but what
about characters like Professor X and
Yoda they both have issues with walking
but there's some of the most powerful
characters in their worlds I think a lot
of mentors have physical handicaps
because it reflects how they favor mind
over body they've transcended physical
limitations to the point where it
doesn't reflect the weakness a similar
injury is blindness this trope goes as
far back as added his reps when the
blind man can tell the future while
Oedipus is the one seeing things
incorrectly in movies not being tricked
by the world around you seems to give
you a spiritual wisdom instead also have
you ever noticed that every superhero
has a movie where they lose their powers
they can't shoot webs they don't have
their suit or they get blasted with
kryptonite it's because when your life
is threatened when you're no longer
invincible then you become relatable
because what's more human than being
mortal when - pretty much invincible
superheroes fight it's kind of boring
where are the stakes how can we relate
to them Nietzsche was such a
revolutionary movie because for the
first time the alien wasn't a giant
monster a huge impenetrable creature he
was innocent and most importantly he
could get sick making him human I think
one of my favorite examples of bringing
out humanity through injuries is in
Terminator 2 Arnold Schwarzenegger is an
emotionless robot but by the end of the
movie he grows on you and it comes from
his selflessness and how he lets himself
get hurt even with no sympathetic
dialogues no discernible emotion and a
murderous streak the Terminator still
gets a hug in the end and we empathize
with him because he got hurt you know
what here's the thing about die hard for
I heard one of the original John McClane
was this normal guy you know he's just a
normal new york city cop who gets his
feet cut it gets beat up but he's an
everyday guy in die hard for he is
jumping a motorcycle into a helicopter
in the air you know he's invincible at
the end of the day major injuries remind
you of your mortality and may make you
reconsider what's important to you in
film the same principles apply so the
next time somebody gets hurt remember
that it's never just a flesh wound
thanks for watching
[Music]
the only